okay hello and welcome to our webinar
today I am Kieran O'Keefe partner at
Denton's Global advisors in Brussels and
we are here today to discuss the AI act
and in particular general purpose AI
which I am going to refer to as GPI for
the duration of this uh discussion this
afternoon
following the draft AIX proposal by the
Commission in 2021 many AI experts have
highlighted the need for the AIX to deal
with the ongoing Trend towards more
General AI systems business open course
to regulate general purpose of AI or
what has been called the brain of AI
we're here today to discuss that brain
and the most effective way to regulate
them to ensure that they are safe
the concepts of GPI properly arrived in
the scene with the May 2022 proposal by
the French presidency of the Union
in this proposal the presidency
identified a number of articles in the
acts that need to specifically apply to
Dubai including articles on risk
management
systems and data governance the current
check presidency has reaffirmed this
overall approach but has proposed the
GPA are regulated through implementing
Acts
there are various factions in the
parliament uh have to take on a wide
range of proposals on this topic some
have copied the French proposal others
have suggested that all AI systems with
indeterminate uses and other ways to
describe GPI are classified as high risk
a third group within uh renew in the
European Parliament has instead
suggested that only requirements around
cyber security accuracy and robustness
should be imposed
as we are now approaching the final
discussions uh in the Parliament and
with the trial log on the horizon the
question becomes how can we best tackle
GPI and in the final legal text and we
have an excellent panel of speakers here
this afternoon with us to discuss this
subject
Kenny and gross has been head of unit
for policy development and coordination
in relation to AI since January 2020.
prior to this kidian was a member of the
cabinet of commissioner ottinger a role
he fulfilled from 2015 and between 2010
and 2015 Kenny was deputy and acting
head of units and teaching energy where
he dealt with policy coordination of the
energy sector and he started his
commission career in the legal service
and before that as an in-house lawyer
specializing in addition
Jenny Brennan is a senior researcher at
the Ada Lovelace Institute where she
needs work on ethics and accountability
in practice her research includes
methods for inspecting and assessing
algorithmic systems and the impact on
people and Society
bridging policy and Technology Journey
brings data engineering experience from
Twitter and entrepreneur first as well
as Consulting with early stage startups
or projects ranging from developing AI
personal assistance to software for kids
learning to code foreign
policy coordinating the organization's
Global advocacy and policy efforts with
the European institutions in Brussels
the U.S federal government and the
United Nations he works to limit the
risks from artificial intelligence to
society and to expand support for a
treaty on lethal autonomous weapons
before joining uh fli Mark was in the
Dutch civil service and served as a
diplomat in the Netherlands Embassy in
Iraq yeah I was a bachelor's degree in
philosophy politics and economics from
the University of Oxford and has a
master's degree from the John Hopkins
University School of advanced
International Studies
we will also be joined uh shortly by
Brando benefit that he's not currently
on the call who will be joining us
momentarily
Brando joined the European Parliament in
2014 serving in his first mandate on the
employment Committee in European
Parliament since 2019 he's been a member
of the committee on the internal Market
in consumer protection
in 2020 he joined the special committee
on artificial intelligence in a digital
age and is currently co-reparator on the
artificial intelligence Act
in a moment I'm going to ask our
speakers to make some shortly remarks
for our participants I should let you
know that if you would like to ask a
question then there is a q a function
where you can post a message and I will
take questions from there as our
discussion progresses and pose them to
our panelists
I would also just briefly like to draw
your attention to the global ai ai
survey which has been developed by our
colleagues at densons which is assessing
the extent of business Readiness for AI
transformation
this can be found on the Denson's
website and my colleague Julia will be
emailing its own disasters with a link
to that survey and you are more than
welcome to participate in it
so
now we've had an introduction to today's
discussion and let's start with some
opening remarks from our speakers
um on GPI so kidding as the commission
with the original authors of the AI acts
perhaps you could start us off with your
thinking thank you
thanks a lot um Kieran and thanks a lot
for having me here today on this
important discussion indeed general
purpose AI or foundational II is an
increasing branch of AI and therefore
the questions which we're addressing
today are of increasing importance and
how to get the regulation right meaning
how to make sure that these systems are
as transversy as other AI systems which
have a dedicated purpose intended
purpose from the beginning on the one
hand side and on the other side not to
prevent the further development of these
often as well very promising systems in
AI to help us as well in Europe to
innovate and to be at the Forefront of
Cutting Edge AI
um website I can just summarize a little
bit the the journey which we did already
on general purpose aiq run highlighted
already the big landmarks but I may dig
a little bit deeper perhaps
when we did our proposal we had in April
2021 we had not a specific provision on
AI this is correct nevertheless general
purpose AI or general purpose AI general
purpose AI was not excluded from the
regulation on the contrary because our
understanding was that with our proposal
every AI system which would not
particularly exclude high risk purposes
would fall under the regulation so
the presumption was you know that we
have taken a horizontal approach in the
AI act we've taken a product-based
approach and the determining factor for
the risk classification is the intended
purpose of a given system so what do you
want to do with that system
if a general purposely I the system
would include as well high risk purposes
in our understanding in the initial
proposal it would become a high risk
system in that respect which would need
to undergo the X underconformity
assessment and would need to comply with
the requirements for high risk systems
so it's not it was not excluded of
course there was the possibility always
for the provider to explicitly exclude
the users first seen in the different
annexes in the regulation and by that
um avoiding to having to comply with the
AI regulation in this respect the
requirements for high-risk systems
nevertheless if in that case it was our
initial proposal if in that case a
provider down the line would decide to
use for instance a general purpose AI or
the language processing tool for
instance for a high risk purpose this
second provider would then become the
provider of the hybrid system it would
then need to undergo these under
Conformity assessment
um we would expect that was our
presumption that then the provider of
the general purpose AI references a
language processing tool would cooperate
on a commercial basis with the provider
down the line which would who would then
give a specific purpose to the AI system
so that would be because there would be
a commercial interest in order to allow
to exploit all possible
um uses of this AI system that should be
in commercial incentive for the provider
as a general purpose AI to work together
with the provider of the AI which would
use that general purpose AI for a
specific high risk purpose that was our
our vision would be laid out in the
initial proposal just to be very clear
because you will if you look at this you
will not find a specific chapter but
this was the way how we understood the
general rules would apply to a general
purpose AI then uh
the as we went along I have as well to
say that the market development and the
technological development if you look at
GPT 3 and so on have really taken speed
and the topic was much more prominent on
the table than it was perhaps when we
started this process the Slovenia
presidency reflected on this and they
took the decision to take general
purpose AI out of the scope also
regulation to accept Exempted and only
to kick in once a high risk purpose was
uh was given to the specific system this
led to I think really triggered and
really a lot of public discussion uh in
in the parliament but as well as a lot
of stakeholders
um and even some quite a strong
reactions and I think as a as a reaction
to this public debate the French
presidency then
um try to modify this approach again and
went a little bit back backwards towards
the original commission thinking but now
explicitly stating this in the ACT
namely by putting into the act that the
AI the general purpose AI should be
subject to the um through the regulation
with certain adaptations uh based on the
fact that general purpose AI has not
just just one specific purpose versus
opal for a lot of different purposes so
they've tried to adapt the requirements
unless there was a specific exception
um it was it was explicitly clarified by
the provider that all high-risk use
cases were except Exempted and deposit
now what we first saw as a kind of
commercial
interoperation was now it has become now
a legal obligation namely between the
provider as a general purpose AI to
cooperate with the provider down the
line who would give a specific purpose
to that system so now that this is the
idea of a of a legal obligation to
cooperate between these two and they
introduce an exception for smes so if
SNES would come and produce a general
purpose AI they would at this stage be
accepted from the um from the
obligations the Czech presidency now has
developed this and on this basis I think
has Fine due to six this model which the
French have introduced a bit further
they mainly have not specified in detail
which how the adaptation of the
requirements in uh to the general
purpose that I should really be worked
out but they have foreseen
um in a delegate in implementing act for
the commission which should be adopted
within 18 months after the entry into
false assist regulation where where the
specificities the detailed application
adaptation of the general of the
requirements should be fixed in order to
make clear how the um the the
requirements would have to be applied to
a general purpose AI
in order to be appropriate in addition
they foreseen a second implementing act
in order to specify which kind of
information the provider of general
purpose I would have to give to the
provider who would attach a specific
purpose to this Ai and would then make
it a specific high-risk AI system this
is now the proposal which is on the
table and which is supposed we have to
see what happens which is supposed to be
adopted by the ministers on the 6th of
December in order to um to now to agree
on a general approach and that would in
that case if the minister then agree who
becomes a starting point for the council
to negotiate what if Kirin already
pointed out and I think that's a very
important point this is only of course
one side of the table or of the medal
the other side is the European
Parliament where the discussion is still
going on and the European Parliament is
still reflecting on finding its position
or concluding on its decision there are
different views and different um
ideas how to do this but then of course
afterwards there will be the dialogues
and the final
um the final outcome will then depend on
how the European Parliament positions
itself and what is then the final line
on which both institutions can agree I
hope this gives you a first overview of
where we stand currently thanks
thank you
Channing can I ask you please just to
give your perspective and the
perspective of the adapt Lovelace
Institute
thanks so much Karen um I'm really happy
to get the opportunity to discuss uh
general purpose Ai and the kind of
implications of this this changing area
value chain
um these issues are really essential to
adequately answer the question of how to
regulate increasingly powerful systems
and to have a future-proofed AI act
um so general purpose AI presents
potentially a more complex value chain
than many of the context specific AI
systems people have been you know often
thinking about and discussing
um in the regulatory space and the
proposition of these being increasingly
the norm is performance of more
generalized models rapidly increases and
the adaptation and adoption into
products is happening at PACE
um so the AI value chain really involves
multiple providers in in the opponents
of the AI act which would be developers
um of AI models and users which would be
um deployers but that simple delineation
is not perfectly fitting um through the
context of general purpose AI systems
um in some cases there'll be those fine
tuners in the middle who build on top of
AI models end users who then operate the
system for example in in the workplace
um and most importantly from our
perspective at Ada affected persons at
the end of the value chain people whose
lives these systems impact uh so imagine
you might have a language generation
model like gpt3 which might be embedded
into a product to generate copying for
adverts which may in turn be used by a
company to generate a job advert and
then why then be be viewed and
interpreted by a person
um and applicant at the other end and
any of these kind of product
implementation adaptations will have
lots of different stages in in those
processes
um and is the impact of AI systems on
affected persons in society that we're
most concerned about
um and it's clear that there are certain
risks of harm to people which can emerge
from the Upstream designer development
um uh for example um we've seen kind of
text generation models
um propagating extremist content or
biased against different bias against
different groups based on training data
from the web or image generation models
results being skewed by gender or race
when prompted with particular adjectives
or roles
or behaviors of humans
um so how can we think about mitigating
um mitigating harms and AIA framework
well risks can emerge in the AI systems
during design development and uh
deployment and there on through the AI
lifecycle
um these systems are dynamic as they
evolve or adapt and can operate a really
global scale
um so we think that risk kind of
mitigating these risks and harms
involves clearly designating
responsibility and for us there's three
layers to this some requirements I mean
the provider can do some that should be
done uh by the the user and some that
should be done by both provider and user
um
so
um however I have to say a fair
designation of responsibility
um it's not the end of the conversation
when we talk about responsibility in the
value chain you also have to think what
that means many providers argue that
it's hard to mitigate Downstream risks
as they're dependent on the context of
use
um yet at the same time many of these
general purpose AI providers
um also represent powerful players at
the start of the value chain which many
smaller providers rely upon so options
could include things like know your
customer requirements
um requiring uh developers the most
cutting-edge foundational models to
interrogate who their clients are the
intended uses and confirm if those uses
end up taking place
um there needs to be an incentive and
provide us to check who they're just
selling to else you could end up with a
market which will providers are selling
to anyone with no due diligence
requirements
um
and and this matters because at the end
of the day we can't talk about general
purpose Ai and the value chain without
considering those impacted by The
Cutting Edge systems we're talking about
um a more holistic approach is needed
Beyond just designating responsibilities
in the value chain those who are
affected should be involved in the
entire process from standards
development
um to Future oversight and governance
um and this uh kind of interventions
from here may range from independently
and adequately resourced oversight body
with a fundamental rights remit um
through to considerations of fundamental
rights impact assessments
um and most importantly the inclusion of
effective persons and and in standard
setting bodies and and institutions
um so we're really seeing a need for a
kind of holistic consideration across
the value chain of of different
implications of general purpose AI I'm
really excited to discuss that further
with everyone today
thank you Jenny
that's a very helpful uh promise to the
discussion
Mark can I ask you to give your and
flies perspective please on the
discussion topic
yes thank you Kieran for uh for inviting
us on this panel and um I won't go into
the value chain I think as Jenny has has
done that uh and I I won't possibly be
able to to repeat that what I'd like to
focus on a little bit is why we care
about these systems as fli uh as well as
the definition
um and I think the reason why we care so
much about these systems is because and
I think as Killian already highlighted
that these systems were brought up by
many AI researchers and developers when
they looked at the AI act as something
that was emerging just around when the
text was first published
um but we also care because of the harms
and in the United States Representative
escho um in the House of Representatives
two months ago called for the regulation
of these systems in a U.S context after
stable diffusion came out and stable
diffusion is an AI model that allows you
to generate images based on text and I
quote the representative who said that
this system can be and reportedly has
been used to create images including
propaganda violent imagery pornography
images that potentially violate
corporate copyrights and images used for
disinformation and misinformation
campaigns and general purpose AI systems
power the development of AI at the
moment but they've also been documented
to be islamophobic anti-semitic to by
accident disclose private banking
information to recommend suicide to
patients although in a simulated
environment and to generate fake news
and it's all of these various harms that
we are particularly concerned about
especially if they emerge at the
beginning at the source of the value
chain and are not directly put onto the
market but are only discovered further
Downstream
um so then the question I think in terms
of Regulation becomes if we're concerned
about all these harms how do we Define
general purpose AI systems and there's
been a lot of discussion that everything
is a general purpose AI system and I'd
really want to push back on that here in
this panel
um we've written a paper where we've
defined general purpose AI systems as AI
systems that can accomplish or be
adapted to accomplish a range of
distinct tasks including some for which
they weren't intentionally trained and I
think that last sentence including tasks
that they weren't intentionally trained
for is a really critical element in the
definition uh kylian mentioned gpt3
which is a system that basically
predicts the next word and it was
discovered later that it could also be
applied to answering questions
translation doing basic arithmetic
writing code and all of these
capabilities were capabilities that gpt3
wasn't specifically trained for
similarly stable to Fusion designed to
generate images wasn't set up to be a
studio for child pornography but it only
became a studio for child pornography
after it was released and someone tried
to use it in that way and that is why we
are so concerned about these systems but
also why we think that we need to be
very careful about about the definition
because this definition would not
include recommender systems it would not
include Voice assistance and many of the
the other systems that some have
suggested would also fall under this
heading
um I want to briefly say one word on the
economic component and I hope we get to
talk a bit more about that later in the
panel but there's only some companies
that really have the the capital to be
able to produce these systems and
um I think we can talk about those
companies it's meta it's Google it's
open AI it's Baidu it's these four
companies that are really really Central
to the development of foundational or
general purpose AI systems at the moment
and similar to the Ada Lovelace
Institute the future of Life Institute
would recommend applying all the
requirements of title 3 chapter 2 to
Providers such as making sure that the
providers report on cyber security
accuracy robustness have solid risk
management systems but again also making
sure that users take their
responsibility because they know what
the specific use cases so it's really a
question about balancing these
requirements across the different
entities and making sure both groups of
parties essentially play the role that
they ought to
um so in some I think we feel it's
necessary for allocating the right
responsibilities in the value chain but
also to really protect people from harm
that we feel that it's so critical that
the AI Act deals with general purpose AI
systems in this way
thanks very much Mark for those
introduction remarks and welcome Brando
to our discussion here this afternoon
thank you very much for joining us I
would like to come to you now to give
you the opportunity to ask you a few
remote to give some remarks at the
beginning of this discussion
um Brando from early stage in this
debate you and others have talked about
no car votes for GPI but of course the
debate has now moved on a little bit
focusing Less on if we should regulate
GPI but more how we should regulate GPI
and we will be Keen to do your initial
thoughts on that particular Point
Brandon please
the floor is yours
you're on mute yes sorry but I didn't
hear very well what you have said I see
I I'm
I I had some problems in in the sound I
don't know why nope um can you can you
hear me now
uh yeah can you repeat please yes yes so
I was in the introduction I was just
noticing the fact that from an early
stage in the discussion uh you and
others have talked about no carve outs
for general purpose AI systems uh of
course the debate has moved on a little
bit from if we should regulate those
rather than how so the best way to
regulate those and therefore I was
looking for your initial thoughts on
that on that subject yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah thank you
um for this uh invitation
um I I I I can stay very much because we
have meetings here in Bali I mean but I
will try to give a little input on this
um we have been uh working on different
topics but also
um on
um and I mean some contentious issues
one of them is is this how we regulate
the general purpose AI
um
uh we
um uh we we we we we
um
um have been
um discussing
um
where we can find about how we can find
the balance on
um
um uh on on avoiding uh possible
loopholes
um
and at the same time recognize the
differences between the different
systems that we are
regulating we don't want and we we want
to be sure that we do not
um risk
um that there is a a free end uh for um
those that are producing general purpose
AI to just bring all the responsibility
all the
um
situation of uh checking the impact on
fundamental rights and the respect of
the rules needed for the system to be
operating only on
um the intermediate user or the final
even the final user
um
we have been working in general to um
um
consider uh in this chain of
responsibility
some degree of impact assessment by the
users so a fundamental rights impact
assessment is being discussed today in
particular regarding the vulnerable
individuals
um
the stakeholder engagement and effective
enforceability
this is something that uh also is part
of the approach that we are taking on
the general purpose AI that we still
haven't concluded what we we will
actually put as a compromise proposal
from the parliament but we do not want a
special categories we want the rules to
be applied for everyone and we need to
uh look at how in this specific case
um we can ensure that there is a
um the correct allocation of
responsibility so we are working on that
um and this is in fact something that in
the next weeks will be coming to some
solution also in the discussion in
nepalian
thank you Brando for those initial uh
contributions and just would like to
remind briefly our attendees that who
would like to post questions and they
can do so through the Q a function uh in
the webinar but I'm going to start the
discussion by posing some questions
um uh to our panelists in Mark's initial
remarks we talked about the importance
of trying to find more precisely uh what
we're talking about when we talk about
uh dupai and we shared some ideas there
for how he thinks uh a definition could
be uh refined to more precisely Target
the type of technology that we are
really considering
Jenny I wonder whether or not you had
any initial Reflections on Mark's
perspective and whether or not you had
uh yourself any views on how more
precisely could Define what we're
talking about Jenny
thank you and yeah I'd really Echo that
thought that I think there's um some
real sense in thinking about uh how we
refine that definition
um we're in a broad definition risks
capturing systems that used to be could
be used for multiple purposes but not
necessarily in high risk areas whereas a
target of of Duty by specific position
Provisions we're really looking at the
most powerful collecting Edge systems
that are truly kind of multimodal or can
be applied to human areas that they've
weren't originally trained for and this
issue in particular when we're thinking
about
um a lot of things which you know when
we're looking at risk and we're looking
at context one of the challenges of
these systems is that we don't have that
upfront context
the point of of
um of development of more uh broad
multi-purpose systems
um where kind of Upstream in the value
chain
um where it can be difficult to see all
of the cases
um that that the system could be used
for yet the inputs and and process of
development and information about that
model will be incredibly important
um throughout the process in terms of
understanding potential risks challenges
and and and and and indeed to Brando's
Point fundamental rights
um events which was very promising to
hear about
thank you Jenny Kelly in the same
question to you actually in relation to
Mark's remarks and you know his
Reflections on how uh we could more
precisely Define Jeep by obviously
you've watched I'm sure these
discussions very carefully as to exactly
you know how to define from the legal
perspective what we're talking about and
you yourself and your introductory marks
talks about foundational models
um rather than using the term GPI so
what are your
what are your observations on some of
those discussions so far and where you
think some of the interesting ideas
might be as to how to properly Define
what we're talking about
okay thanks a lot when it is clear
whenever we introduce some specific
rules for for general purpose AI we need
to find some some definition because
it's that's clear in this legal context
the counter the presidency has
introduced one in article three there's
now a definition of general purpose AI
uh which takes up I think some of the
ideas which you which you have to
discussed and the key thing here is of
course that there are more than one
purpose behind such a system and it may
even be intended it may be used but it
says here in the priority of context and
maybe integrated in a polarity of other
AI systems I think this is one way of
expressing this idea
um you can of course discuss whether
this is the best possible way but this
is one way of expressing the idea that
you do not have the singular um intended
purpose but you may have this may as
well be used kind of a pre-product to
build something else on top of this but
we'll then have a specific purpose
or we'll narrow down the purpose this is
a bit I think the underlying feature and
this is important for our act because
as I said for us the intended purpose is
a key feature to identify which kind of
risk category you you're in because we
we really look at this and look because
that's a bit defining a bit the frame
because the provider defines with the
intended purpose for what the system
should be used and he or she tries to
make the system then safe and
trustworthy for that given intended
purpose that's in the general feature in
the in our in our system if then the
user goes beyond that intended purpose
this becomes a substantial modification
and the user becomes a provider by
itself which I think is the same idea
which you have in classical products at
the station if you for instance have a
car and you you modify the car
substantively you cannot benefit anymore
for the type approval you have to get
the new type approval because it becomes
at one point a new car this is the idea
so you define with the intended purpose
what kind of car this is or what kind of
AI this is and this I think is the key
feature for this for this definition
that you um relate to the idea that
there is not just one purpose but there
is a multitude of purposes in the
multitude of different users how this AI
system May later on be used
thank you I want to also I mean other
than
the debate about how to exactly Define
GPI one of the points in the discussion
so far that is uh proved the source of
debate is the extent to which it is
appropriate that open source
should be included within the scope of
any obligations for uh dupai you know
the one hand open source is important
for technological development and on the
other hand an exemption could provide
the means for some providers to size
debt compliance with the AI act I'm
wondering how our panelists might view
this trade-off and perhaps actually I
could come to you Brando first on this
point
how are you looking at this issue of
Open Source in relation to G Prime
I
I I still didn't hear your your last
question sorry can you repeat I don't
know I don't have a problem today with
the audio I'll repeat so uh whereas I'm
asking about open source uh and the
extent to which you know this should be
in the scope of any obligations on
General AI systems so do you want to
maybe share your thinking on that
particular podcast yeah yeah yeah yeah
we landed on that yeah yeah okay I I
understood sorry I don't know I have
some problem with the connection uh I
hope you can hear me well
um
and on the open source
um I I have to say that
um
although some colleagues favor an
exception for the use of the open source
uh I and my group we are a bit more
cautious the principle we are trying to
avoid is that those who release this
type of Technology are exempt from
um responsibility and also liability for
any damages resulting from Downstream
use
um
the effects of which are also due to the
Upstream design there is no doubt about
the value of the open source but
shifting all the obligations into the
smes because this is what I think would
happen is not uh in my opinion a good
choice so uh I I would say I have this
much more cautious approach and we are
still discussing about it
thank you brande can I post the same
question to Mark where do you stand on
on open source and it's inclusion
yeah I think I mean it's it's a
difficult question I think given how
important open source is for development
of AI systems
um and I think it's it's only recently
that we've seen a lot of companies
produce very large systems and putting
them out as open source um basically
untested to see what the public response
is and to see if they can tweak these
models before they maybe
um sell an approved version and then
don't sort of provide it as open source
but provide it through an API
um interface for example
um so I think increasingly we feel that
open source
um as Brando has highlighted needs to be
addressed in the same way as as any
other AI system to really avoid this
phenomenon where companies offload their
responsibility uh under the AI act by
publishing a model as open source
um and and shirking responsibility I
mean I was a little bit
um sneaky maybe in my opening remarks
referring to stable diffusion because
that of course is an open sour Source
model where the CEO has said to people
that if they want to use stable
diffusion in a way that's generally
deemed inappropriate to then please do
so on their own servers and not on on
sort of the the companies um and I think
that's a that's really an example of an
actor that isn't taking its
responsibility serious uh seriously and
I think it's it's an example of an actor
that I think ought to be addressed by
regulators and I think it's why it's
caused such upheaval in the U.S House of
Representatives as well and why there's
been this debate
um so I would feel that that we would
also need to ensure that open source
systems are in scope
um in one way or another
Jenny
your perspective please yeah thank you
for these comments so far I think
um the kind of the the challenges in the
trade-offs we see here
um is that uh you know on one side we're
aware that open source can bring
significant Downstream Innovation
um also potentially supports important
Safety and Security research on general
purpose AI in terms of providing open
source models has a lot of benefit in
terms of research access and and
development
um but we can't get away from the impact
on affected persons at the end of the
line
um and that they also pose similar risks
uh in in a similar manner to to closed
Source gpis in many dimensions
um and so we there's a couple of
scenarios we obviously uh want to avoid
would be kind of the open sourcing
um of of of commercial models
effectively kind of alleviating uh
alleviating obligations
um and and we can see particularly I
think uh radio we've been thinking about
um there are kind of a minimum set of
requirements that perhaps don't seem
overly burnt and so
um things like data quality evaluations
kind of 100 article 10 technical
document adaptation article 11. um
without those that could be really uh
kind of low quality or risky models
um and and that products are then
subsequently being built from without
any ability for Downstream fine tuners
to assess the risks and understand the
systems that they're building on top of
um and so I think I think there's uh
still challenges around kind of uh who
the actors are in that place
predominantly to Mark's Point we've
actually seen this nominated by kind of
large uh larger organizations or
organizations uh with kind of commercial
potentially attached but you could
imagine the scenario of a collective of
Open Source developers
um uh uh being a more challenging kind
of been around scrounge around liability
but I think nonetheless we still have to
come down to what is the set of impacts
and affected users and how can we help
mitigate them
thank you Jenny
Killian is this a point that the
commission has reflected on as you kind
of observed the evolving discussions on
general purpose AI systems
no of course we are reflecting on this
this is an important important question
um
I think
from I have to say as as Brando said we
are they are still a bit in the
reflection mode I I wouldn't say that we
have a completely final position because
it's not it's not an easy and easy task
um but perhaps just my my thoughts I
think the key element for us is that
they get it right so that they get
requirements for a general purpose AI
which are feasible and do not kill
Innovation and if we manage this in the
end the system is well applicable to um
these kind of general purpose AI we
presented as an open source I think then
we should that will be um I I think a
feasible option because in the end we
have to make sure that it must be our
purpose we're going to have this balance
between Innovation and trustworthiness
but we must as well make sure that every
high-risk system
delivers the same provides the same
level of of trust and stability and
robustness and accuracy and that cannot
depend on the way it has been developed
so that is well we need as well to see
that a little bit from the end how can
we make sure that after after all
notwithstanding the value chain how it
has been developed the result is as good
as it had would be if it had been
directly developed for a given purpose
therefore we think uh so one thing is
really key is um that we make the
require that they really think it's true
that the requirements fit for their
purpose Ai and I do not close in an
obstacle which is difficult to to
overcome too difficult to overcome and
second it's perhaps not a bad an
interesting idea what the council has
put in this derogation for smes in
particular so for small Innovative
companies to release them a bit and
there they have some opening I mean this
is one of the ideas the council
presidency has introduced it's not
related to the technology it's related
to the size of the company it's a bit of
a different approach of course but it's
uh the idea I think is based
um on the fact that if a small
Innovative company uh comes up with such
a such a true such a general purpose AI
system then it may not be able or maybe
more difficult for them to to look at
the um at the requirement and therefore
to help them there so that may as well
be that may as well cover quite a good
part of innovative open source software
thank you Kelly and also thank you for
raising the point of uh I I need
unfortunately to leave for a meeting but
thanks for this opportunity I hope I
gave a few useful inputs thank you very
much thank you Brian I wish you the best
uh
Kelly and I'm also value time is is
getting on for you you may have to leave
momentarily so if there are any sort of
final remarks that you also want to uh
you also want to make then please
feel free to do something no perfect I'm
very sorry that I have to leave you
because this discussion is extremely
exciting and I would like to to stay
much much more
um
I think uh yes in the end I think it's
but for me but to discuss all the
results that indeed it is worth further
reflecting how we get it right it's not
it's not a simple topic where you just
black and white how you can solve it how
we can adapt the the rules in a way uh
that in the end ensure this high level
of of trust person is I think is key so
that we really think through and that
requires from our perspective a really
good understanding of the value chain
and a good understanding on who can do
what in this in this chain which in
general purpose of course gets a bit
more complex because you do not only
have one provider but you may have sent
several providers down the line who have
to cooperate in one way or another and
the second thing is of course they're
how to organize this cooperation between
these providers do you need rules for
this or do you just trust that the
bucket will ensure that this cooperation
will will work out I think these are for
us the key questions against which we
need to measure any kind of solution
which we which we present
this being said I wish you a good
continuation and I'm very interested and
to listen uh I know this will be
recorded over here and to listen what
you continue to discuss so thanks a lot
and hope to speak to you soon bye bye
thank you for your participation much
appreciated
so for our attendees we will continue
because we still have some uh time in
our in our social program and I want to
pick up on the point that Killian was
making in relation to SMB exemptions
obviously this was a point as well that
was reflected in the French text when we
came to GPI however I want to listen to
your remarks Mark Few thoughts about
Google meta Baidu not smes and anybody's
definition no matter how creative you
can get with that so I'm just wondering
how useful you think sne assumptions uh
might be in relation to cheap I
generally
yeah so I think most of our concerns and
I think the systems that we've analyzed
in terms of potentially causing harm are
not produced by small companies so I
think if um it's not been uh top of our
mind I think um and when the council
suggested this
um yeah
um it's not been something that we found
particularly concerning or had a very
strong view on
um when you look at the top hundred of
um sort of AI startups um by valuation
um there's only three that attempt
um to build general purpose AI systems
the other 97 are working on narrow use
cases so I think it kind of shows
already
um that for most companies it just isn't
feasible
um one example of a sort of startup if
you will that is attempting to produce
general purpose AI systems is anthropic
um but they are sort of cheating
um if you will because they were
previously or most of their team was
part of open Ai and that operates under
license from Microsoft and sort of split
away to to develop their own system so I
think it's quite it's quite rare to see
smes attempt this
um I think it'd be really good for
competition if we can ensure this and if
we can find ways to support smes to
um perhaps compete in this space and
ensure that it is in a few companies
that monopolize the future of AI but
there might be other ways to do that for
example by helping them through funding
um or by supporting them in complying
with the regulation rather than through
a blanket exemption
um which might not really help sort of
solve the problem
um and um yeah I think the ultimate aim
is to try and see if we can get smes
competing rather than making the
regulation a lot more confusing
potentially
thanks Mom uh Jenny I want to use your
knowledge in particular just to get a
bit more information about what what is
the sort of trend you know within AI
development obviously we're talking
about how you future proof uh rules so
this legislation that can have the
longest shelf life possible what are
your observations on you know the kind
of General Trends within AI development
and
therefore do we need to carefully take
into account when we're talking about
legislation
yeah I think this is a great question
and I think
um I think one of the the big challenges
about this is just just how lives how
life these kind of changes are
um if we think about it uh Dali which is
uh open ai's large scale
um uh image generation model the first
version of that only came out in January
2021 and It produced little 250 or 260
pixels by 260 pixel images uh which you
know only goes so far and yet a year
later it was producing kind of large
high quality images
um and and considerably more
feature-rich and considerably more
impactful so we're seeing significant
progress in in in in the performance of
more generalized
um models and we're also seeing a really
rapid productization right so uh taking
that example again Microsoft is already
uh uh announced that it will be
integrating that model into its
Microsoft designer product and it's edge
browser which in terms of in terms of
going from uh new emerging technology
into on the laptops of the masses uh
it's an incredibly fast
um fast turnaround
um and so it feels like there is this
this trend uh towards a couple of pieces
in this one just towards more of these
kind of broader purpose uh in GPI
foundational models as the starting
point and then finer training and tuning
being
um uh being the kind of space where we
see more smaller actors smes step in
um and also I think uh there's also
things around means of access and means
of using these right again a lot of our
thinking about
um about this comes as like oh you know
if we're thinking about this in a kind
of product mindset but we're also seeing
a lot of kind of AI as a service type
products uh where access and use of
these models will be done by apis
um and and so the actual product
experience of building something like
this this will be I'll hook into the API
for this general purpose AI model I'll
hook that into the system that I'm
building and the product I'm making and
then it will go out to the user and so
there's this kind of ongoing
relationship between the original AI
model generator and the product
um and then there's just a kind of a
very very different pattern of behaviors
and interactions
um then maybe uh some of the kind of
initial more context specific or product
uh kind of founded thinking of of AI
development may have set up
thanks Jenny do those observations
resonate with you Mark or are there
other things that you would also like to
emphasize
then I think uh I I think what Jenny's
highlighted in terms of how quick
um these systems go from sort of the
development stage to potentially being
integrated in in Microsoft browsers or
or sort of
um that ex end users get exposed to them
um is sort of a feature that the AI act
will need to Grapple with um and
potentially the AI boards or the AI act
in visages can play a role in making
sure that with the space of the
technology we ensure that the regulation
stays up to date
um because as much as we try to foresee
and analyze some of these developments
now there will definitely be
developments that we can't foresee
um but it was uh Tech monitor I think
one or two years ago that did some
analysis on sort of the economic
prospects for for these systems
um these large language models these
these large general purpose AI systems
um and where they're headed expecting a
doubling of the market size between 2022
and 2025 to 47 billion US Dollars and I
think that that sort of indicates the
direction of travel and I think
um Europe and sort of the AI act ought
to be ready for that because as of yet
all of this
um development happens in the United
States and China
um and it's um I think it falls to
Europe to also protect its citizens from
some of the potential harmful impacts
thanks Mark
um I just want to come back a little bit
to some of the options that are
currently on the table or under
discussion
um you know Gideon was Keen to
emphasizing his introductory remarks the
kind of risk-based approach the
commission took when they were crafting
the original text and some of the
proposals on the table right now to
regulate their GPI well they would
probably impose obliga you know many if
not all the obligations reserved for
high risk uh applications onto that
technology do you think that's a fair
expectation of of systems or do we need
a more targeted approach in your opinion
the mobile marketing starting that point
and then Jenny would follow up foreign
yes I mean I think
um and maybe in response to to Brando's
points even though he's he's not here
anymore
um I think I can see that the
institution scrappling with the fact
that they want to preserve the the
Integrity of the AI acts and its initial
design yet there is now this new class
of systems that that sort of poses
different questions and how you can sort
of square that circle is a really tough
and challenging question I do think that
some of the requirements in the AI act
can't be made to apply in full to
general purpose AI systems I think human
oversight is a really good example of
that where it's really hard to ensure
human oversight if if the company
doesn't know the exact use case in which
a downstream provider might use the
system I think some logging requirements
are also probably not feasible
um
overall I would say that the operating a
risk management system some of the data
and data governance requirements
um are examples of things that that
should definitely fall on the on the
sort of um general purpose AI system
provider
um but I do think there's some
um yeah that they simply cannot
um abide by which makes me think that
that we need something a little bit more
creative and tailored um than just
um classifying everything under the high
risk bracket
thanks Mark Jenny your thoughts on the
same subject
yeah I think I I got some of that and
maybe uh would also kind of add around
that I think
um first reflect that I guess we think
um it's not necessarily a huge ask to
have providers comply with with a set or
many of the high risk requirements
um it was a China Bryson who uh kind of
described even the full set of
obligations uh is pretty lightweight um
in places
um I there's a kind of essentially
mainly compelling due diligence via
self-assessment by the companies
themselves that's what's kind of
expected to occur in roughly 90 of use
cases
um possibility of third-party checks by
regulatory authorities are there but
would come further down the line
um so so also to remember the size of
what we're asking in this isn't isn't
necessarily unusable but then also to
Mark's point about kind of where those
responsibilities sit
um and and that is where there will be
need to be some kind of somewhat of a
special regime I think needed uh for
General uh purpose AI in that
um in that I think you know if we look
at uh some of the obligations really
need to sit on the original providers of
potentially high-risk AI alongside users
and and some are more suited uh suited
to users
um so for instance uh you know uh risk
uh management quality criteria technical
documentation
um uh testness tests for system uh
accuracy robustness cyber security Etc
makes sense to happen both at the
general purpose of AI uh kind of
Provider level but may also need to be
repeated again at the user level at the
point of kind of adaptational or
integration into products
um
versus
um some some of those points agreeing
with with Mark that record keeping
throughout the life cycle uh radical 12
provision of information to users human
oversight are quite challenging uh at
that Upstream stage and and really makes
sense to sit more with with users
thanks Jenny I've got a question that is
coming in from our attendees for both of
you uh and that is what is your sense of
how mature the debate about general
purpose AI is outside of the EU context
someone I think that in that case was
you mark mentioned uh representative
issue in the US are there other
countries that are grappling deeply with
these issues who you think have a clear
view of the trade-offs
mark because you were the one that
mentioned representative issue maybe you
could have a quick go with that and then
uh General let me comment
um yeah I I think the AI act in a sense
in Europe forces the debate to be a bit
more mature than elsewhere just because
people Regulators have to make uh tough
decisions now and and as we've heard
from from Killian the council is
wrapping up by December 6th um and the
Parliament is also approaching its
position
um I do feel that some of the large
companies
um open AI for example is sort of
leading that debate maybe in the private
sector where they have
um in their terms of use stated what
uses gpt3 can be used for and what it
can't be used for
um and therefore sort of
um in a way are introducing perhaps some
some Norms that others can can take an
example from
um but no I I yeah I would say that the
debate on this is is by far like yeah
more mature in Europe
um although um institutions such as nist
in the United States are also sort of
debating some of these questions so you
definitely see
um yeah get traces of the debate
elsewhere
same question to you Jim
yes I think I
think I would Echo that that Focus uh in
terms of the EU conversation
um Ada is based in both Brussels and
London I'm actually darling in from
London and the conversation here
um is is earlier in terms of AI
regulation although there is a many
issue many much interest in these issues
um I think there are places where we're
seeing
um Provisions that could be relevant in
in other related kind of algorithmic
governance uh discussions that maybe
haven't yet come come through to this
discussion
um as much
um so for instance even places like uh
discussions around trusted research
access is happening quite a lot on the
ground amongst Civil Society groups um
and in Academia
um and uh has kind of started and has
gone further legislatively in in
conversations around the Digital
Services act and access to kind of
social media platform systems
um but I think actually is very relevant
here to this conversation around General
club's Ai and thinking about what kind
of resourcing and and supporting trusted
research access could be so I think
there are conversations happening in
other spaces that translate across
really well
um but uh but I think uh they're really
kind of here at the Forefront at the
moment thank you Jenny well we are into
our final minute and you know both our
institutional guests Killian and Brando
have left the discussion with the video
mentioned we are recording this so
maybe we use this final minute just for
a few concluding remarks I suppose your
elevator pitch if you write to the
institutions as they uh progress the
discussion on the AI Act
Mark let's start with you what is your
you know what are your final concluding
thoughts on this subject
I'm going to steal my final thought from
Jenny in the sense that this is not a
big ask
um I think that we're we're putting to
these providers
um that these are light requirements
that I think are are necessary to
protect people and we ought to apply
them
um and the the second point I'd like to
make in closing is that we really need
to define the definition such that we
only target those systems that are
really of concern
um and that we don't sort of Loop in um
systems unnecessarily
okay so Jenny Mark story on Sunday maybe
but is there something else you can uh
you want to emphasize in your in your
final conclusions I'm always happy to be
given an extra few words
um I uh think um I think I guess for us
the effective
um regulation of general purpose AI
system will systems will need to really
recognize the potential complexity of
the value chain right the way through to
affected persons
um you know the people in a society that
will be impacted by these systems and
how do we recognize their obligations
you know will need to capture
obligations across across providers
users in the joint Place between but
also ensure at the other end that
affected persons are included in those
mechanisms for for oversight for
standard setting and and uh to Founders
Point around to Human Rights impact
assessments
um all the way through the AI act in
order to have that that comprehensive
governance system
fantastic well Mark Jenny thank you for
your time this afternoon I thank you and
Brando in their absence thank you as
well to our attendees I hope you found
it insightful discussion
uh enjoy the rest of your afternoon